the White House is sending mixed signals
tonight as EPA Administrator Scott
Pruitt is facing new obstacles in his
effort to keep his job the agency lawyer
who originally approved Pruitt
sweetheart condo rental deal with a
landlord linked to a lobbyist now says
he did not have all the facts chief
national correspondent ed Henry who
talked exclusively with Pruitt yesterday
has tonight's update asked today if he
still has confidence in Scott Pruitt his
embattled administrator of the EPA
President Trump suggested he does
but White House officials privately know
this president has previously voiced
support for other cabinet chiefs only to
push them out and CNN is reporting the
president saw Pruitt's interview with
Fox and was not happy is draining the
swamp renting an apartment from the wife
of a Washington lobbyist I don't think
that that's even remotely fair to ask
that question White House officials have
spread word they told Pruitt not to do
the interview but he forged ahead anyway
now CBS News is reporting Pruitt wanted
to use sirens on his official car to get
through Washington traffic and when a
member of his security detail said it
was against the rules that person was
reassigned while a new memo from an EPA
ethics lawyer suggests he only okayed
the apartment arrangement based on
federal gift rules but did not have all
the facts to determine whether it
presented a conflict of interest as The
Daily Beast reported the lobbyist who
rented the apartment to Pruitt had
represented a company involved in a 104
million dollar Superfund cleanup
litigation against the EPA I can't speak
to the future of Scott Pruett I can just
talk about where we are now in addition
to that soft White House backing the
third House Republican today called on
Pruitt to go with an aide to
congresswoman Elise Stefanik saying the
upstate New York lawmaker believes quote
it's in the best interest of the EPA for
mr. Pruitt to resign those supporters of
Pruitt are rallying to his defense
Senator Rand Paul tweeting quote at EPA
Scott Pruett is likely the bravest and
most conservative member of trumps
cabinet we need him to help at real
Donald Trump drain the regulatory swamp
and Kim straw soul a columnist for The
Wall Street Journal has noted that then
President Barack Obama's EPA chief Lisa
Jackson spent nearly twice as much money
on an official trip to China than was
spent on a trip to Italy by Pruitt who
told Fox he believes the media largely
gave Obama a pass do you think if an
Obama cabinet official rented an
apartment here in Washington from the
wife of a Washington lobbyist you don't
think Donald Trump in you know what I
think about it
think about it they won't even look at
those issues back then now the New York
Times is reporting at least five EPA
officials were reassigned or demoted
after they voiced concerns about big
spending on furniture first-class travel
plus the fact that Pruitt wanted an
expanded 20 person protective detail
very large and expensive but he did tell
me in that interview that because of his
effectiveness in overturning regulation
to the left is very angry at him and
he's gotten a lot of death threats
Breton a security concern ed thank you
thank you